[Music]
we're live on location at Stanford
University and joining me today is an
economist author scholar senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution and living
legend dr. Thomas all welcome to the
Rubin report well thank you good to be
with you I feel I have to get the
gushing out first that way we can focus
on the book I don't know that there's
anyone on this mortal coil who's writing
and thinking has influenced me more than
you so this this is truly an honor for
me and I just have to get that out right
at the beginning I just hope I haven't
miss laser yeah we'll find out I'll let
you know at the end so first I thought I
want do a little bit on your history and
I want to focus on your new book but I
was curious if you have a sense of the
sort of Renaissance that your writing is
having right now with young people
because when I tweet it out that we
finally had you on the show and we've
been trying to make this happen for
quite some time I mean thousands of
responses and I had tons of people just
says please tell him this tell him this
my awakening was because of dr. Tsao all
this are you noticing something
happening right now because of the
unique police work I only know what
people tell me that's even true at
Stanford yeah I only know what my
research is sisters televisions all
right well I will certainly accept that
well take my word for it then so I want
to talk a little bit about your history
for a bit and then we'll then we'll move
on to your new book born North Carolina
yes
grew up in the Bronx Harlem in Harlem
sorry in Harlem tell me a little bit
about some of your formative years well
you know I thought about as I was doing
the research for the first chapter where
I get into the Bur sort of thing now had
my my parents lived a normal lifespan I
would have been the sixth child in the
family they died young and so I was
adopted in infancy and a family as it
only traces an only child in a home with
four adults and in terms of what what I
found in the research on birth order
clearly that was a huge advantage
and so their misfortune was my good
fortune and moreover the family in which
I was raised moved to New York which at
that time had a foster period
educational system that in North
Carolina and foster period of what it is
today
were you always interested in education
I mean even as you know I got a kid a
little kid there was nothing in my
background that will put me there
but fortunately when in Harlem knows a
kid named ready that members of the
family had run into before I ever
arrived from North Carolina on it and he
was a very came from a highly educated
family and they immediately saw the
implications if they could get him to to
sort of mentor me and now I had I had
met Eddie on my own chances I would
never have seen any significance he was
just a vision one of the people I passed
by but of course the other the adults
understood what the future was like and
then thinking about things that kids
don't think about despite the great
worship which a child talkers these days
and so but so he took me to a public
library and I had no idea what a public
library was I was eight years old and I
saw all these books and I had no idea
why we were there when I don't have any
money to buy one book and so what am I
gonna do with all these you know
hundreds of books up on the shelf
and he very patiently walked me through
the whole thing
and again I was very reluctant to take
out a library cause hiding to watch what
all this is about that but he talked me
into it
and I said I bought a couple of books
and really had I not encountered him the
entire rest of the story could not have
been the way it was I mean at some point
I would have learned what a public
library was but by that point it would
be too late yeah I mean when you start
getting in the habit of reading when
you're eight years old
that's a different ballgame than if you
have to wait till you're a teenager it's
too late now
dare I ask if you have any recollection
what you might have taken out of the
library at eight years old one of the
books was the Doctor Dolittle
books I don't know if you know what
those are I think he could talk to the
animals yeah Alison Wonderland
and the rest of them but the I came in
on May and there wasn't school wasn't
open until September so I had no one to
play with and I was just bored to tears
and so I started reading really for the
first time and I got the habit of
reading and on that you know that made
the rest possible yeah were there any
other formative things that happened to
you over those those younger years yes
the same the same fellow it was very
knowledgeable but all about the school
system so when I finished elementary
school and they assigned me to a junior
high school in a very bad neighborhood
he told me that you you can get
transferred and I in fact got
transferred to a much better school
had I gone to that other school I again
the story would have been entirely
different and I one of the one of the
themes of the early part of the book
here is that there are there a whole
number of things that have to come
together and if you don't have all of
those prerequisites then all the
whatever good qualities you have don't
matter and I mentioned illiteracy that
you know in the middle of the 20th
century something like 40% of the adults
in the world we're still illiterate and
so it doesn't matter what their native
talent or any of that came along you
can't read there are a whole lot of
occupation you just simply can't get
into yeah so it's pretty clear from all
the reading of yours that I've done you
put basic education basically is number
one right I mean is that the number one
thing that you can do as a human being
get educated
I guess although I wouldn't carry it too
far because some of the most disastrous
notions in the world who come from
highly educated people with I'm sure
high IQs so perhaps critical thinking
with a little education though I am I
will settle for almost any kind of thing
it's so really that it is oddly rare so
one of the things that I found out that
was sort of amazing about your history
you briefly mentioned it right before we
started you were a Marxist at one time
in your life most people will find this
hard to believe but it is true
but it's not that unusual
most of the leading conservative
thinkers of our time did not start off
as conservator you got a couple like
Bill Buckley and George Will but I mean
Milton Friedman was it was it was a
liberal and a Keynesian a Hayek was a
socialist Ronald Reagan was so far left
at one point the FBI was following him
you know so so there's a huge movement
from the left to the right as people get
older yeah I'm I'm well aware as I
mentioned to you earlier as a former
progressive I understand that that
movement in the modern sense
do you remember sort of what you were
thinking what appeal to you at that time
about Marxism yes I mean there was no
alternative being discussed my first job
was as a Western Union messenger and I
would come home on some nights I would
take the Fifth Avenue bus which cost all
of 15 cents in those days but I figured
I'd splurge now and then and I would
drive it would go away up Fifth Avenue
pass all these Lord and Taylor and all
these fancy places and then across 57th
Street pass Carnegie Hall and down
Riverside Drive now it's sort of the
Gold Coast area and then yes I came
across this long viaduct and it turned
into 130 Fifth Street
suddenly there were the tenements and I
wondered why is this
I mean it's so so it's so different and
then nothing in in schools or most of
the books seem to deal with that and
walks dealt with that so it's it's it's
like winning in an election when there's
only one person running so then what was
your wake up to what was wrong with that
line of thinking facts well we could
probably end the interview right there
facts and specifically my first
professional job I was a summer intern
at the new US Department of Labor and I
realized from dealing with these people
that the US Department of Labor one of
my biggest concern was about minimum
wages it has been for a long time and so
my first night well this is good because
all these people look poor and he'll get
a little higher
and come and so that'll that'll be
helpful and then it's like studied
economics ever gonna see well there's a
downside they may lose their jobs
completely sort of is that and so I
tried when I was at the Labor Department
I tried to talk about that to them and
eventually I came up with some test of
it and when I came up with this test how
we might test this I was waiting to hear
congratulations you said I've had this
and I can see these people were stunned
I said oh this is idiot has stumbled on
something that will ruin us all and I
realized the US Department of Labor had
its own agenda and interests and that
did necessary not necessarily mean that
then that whether four people lost their
jobs or minimum wages when it got higher
pay was their highest priority yeah how
much longer did you last know that would
know that was really the turning point
yeah and then I began to see that all
these government agencies more knots
they have their own institutional
incentives and and you cannot say that
the government is will step in and do
what's right for these people or what
not because they'll do what's right for
themselves so I think a lot of people
watching this and I know because I've
been so open about my own sort of
awakening are going through this right
now they're realizing that the things
that they've been taught for so long are
not the the truth and are not based in
fact when that happened to you and you
started telling other people not just
the people you were working with be it
family and friends what kind of pushback
did you get because it was sort of
radical ideas in a way that you were
talking about that well I find I didn't
feel any need to do a lot a lot of
proselytizing it was enough for me that
that I was now beginning to understand
things I hadn't understood before and
you've noted in the book I have a
mission minimum wage studies and really
they're they're they are incredibly
flawed there's a whole chapter on
numbers and the other thing getting back
to my personal development I mean I left
home when I was 17 no high school
diploma no excuse no job experience and
I discovered that there was not a huge
amount of demand for people like that
but in retrospect decades later when I
do research I realize that in 1948 the
unemployment rate for black 16 and
17-year olds was nine point four for
whites the same age it was ten point two
and those numbers are much smaller than
we were used to in recent decades and
there's no serious racial difference in
fact the blacks and at my age bracket
we're doing just slightly better and of
course one of the things that the
minimum wage law does is that it it
creates unemployment raised it to
multiples of what it was 1948 was that
was a special time because the minimum
wage law was passed in 1938 and in the
intervening ten years there was huge
inflation and the law hadn't gotten
changed and so for all practical
purposes there was no minimum wage law
but had we had these wonderful liberals
insisting that I be paid a living wage
that would support a family of four I
would have been unemployed and I don't
know what that would have let him write
it would probably would not have led up
to everything else so when you wouldn't
when you think about these wonderful
liberals as you just said you know I
think there's sort of two lines of
thinking one is that you know the road
to hell is paved with good intentions I
try not to be super highway it's a super
highway exactly I try not to besmirch
their intentions but then I think there
are people that are either can have
confused thinking or have ulterior
motives
or else what do you think it is as
someone that is so based in fact and
we're gonna get to have plenty of that
fact in a moment what do you think the
thinking is the flaw in the thinking oh
I think it's the idea that you don't
have to check a good-sounding idea
against what actually happens the whole
19th and there are people to this day
who think that the 1960s was just a
great period and and I'll say to them do
you realize how many good trends they're
there the murder rate among black males
had gone down had been going down for
two decades you know by 18 percent in
one decade 22 percent a nice decade and
in 1960
suddenly takes a u-turn straight up and
that was not peculiar to blacks or even
to the United States
Pinker's book about about violence and
you know that throughout what the
Western world the homicide rates did a
u-turn in the 1960s so the question is
what actually happens when you put your
wonderful ideas to work do they produce
the kind of thing you thought they were
gonna produce or do they produce all the
opposite in many areas and they produce
lots of offices yeah I'm glad you
mentioned Steven Pinker I had him on the
show a few weeks ago and I think he's
you know he's one of the clearest
thinkers we have and you know his new
book enlightenment now is that things
are trending more positively
but even hearing that is is very hard
for a lot of people well honey depends
on what your baseline is Pinker is much
more optimistic than I am I I happen to
be very pessimistic about the future but
I hope the optimists are right do you do
you think you're a pessimist by Nature
no but I think having study of so many
things that sounded so good and ended up
so bad it makes me doubt especially when
they're people who are anxious to spout
off with very little study of what
they're talking about yeah we've got a
lot of that these days do you think that
has ramped up or yeah I think social
media seems to amplify things but do you
think it's always been that way about
just sort of this endless pontificating
of people that really don't know what
they're talking about well there's
always been that as long as they've been
human beings but the question is the
magnitude of it and the ability of
various institutions to shut out any
other viewpoint of which the
universities are the worst examples yeah
that I mean when I when I when I see the
riots when charles murray shows up and i
haveno charles murray
I mean if you can demonize Charles where
you can demonize anybody yeah I mean and
I listen to see what are they gonna
quote that he said I've never heard a
single quote of all the books the man
has written and they never quote
anything he said and a lot of what he
said is a direct opposite of what they
claimed he said that tells you a little
bit about state we're in right now so do
you so this
this thing that's happening on college
campuses right now that everyone seems
to think is freezing free speech and and
it seems to be speeches speech that's
generally thought of as right so it's
conservatives libertarians further
people on the right than that you're
saying that's really not a new
phenomenon you you were kind of well it
was not that bad in the nineteen fifties
when I was a Marxist and when Senator
Joe McCarthy was Kara was tracking down
anybody on the Left but I said whatever
I felt like where I felt like it and I
got no such blowback that's really
interesting so McCarthy is talking about
all this stuff but you had no problem
no being at okay here in Washington I
was in Cambridge yeah so--but yeah so
you do think if something has gotten
worse now oh no there was a number of
things you add vanilla diseases for
example well going down at a very steep
rate it was either syphilis or gonorrhea
that was one half as prevalent in 1960
as it was in 1950 that the brilliant
idea was to bring in sex education you
see to avoid unwanted pregnancies and so
on and venereal diseases skyrocketed
unwanted pregnancies teenage pregnancies
skyrocketed it's amazing that so many
people on the Left are able to just
ignore any facts they go against their
theory yeah an image it just does not my
my old mentor at the University of
Chicago enjoy Stiegler organ however
that economists have very little
influence and what what they say makes
very little difference and he was giving
a talk at the Hoover Institution once he
said thanks to the years of dedicated
work by Tom Sowell the next minimum wage
increase will be five cents or less than
it would have been otherwise well that's
what's interesting to me is because as I
as I preface this with you I think that
the writings that you've done all these
years in these books they're becoming
culturally relevant maybe in a way that
they weren't I don't even want to say it
this way but maybe in a way that they
didn't weren't economically relevant do
you understand the point there that I
think there's a cultural relevance to
all the things that you've done for
these last you know forty some odd years
that
seem so actually powerful and impactful
to me right now
which is incredible well when it comes
to impact that's a difference the story
entirely I mean long ago I stopped
accepting invitations to testify before
congressional committees it's an
absolute waste of time they have made up
their minds and they just want to be
able to say they've heard all points of
view and then it pretty much stops there
that's right and I remember once Kenneth
Clark was I was debating him and he was
beside himself because my said suppose
it's sinister influence in Washington
this during the Reagan administration I
told him it might have my influence in
Washington is all you have to worry
about very fortunate bad yeah I have had
I can't think of anything that happened
any different that if I had never said
anything to anybody
you're being very humble saying no I'm
just realistic I'm gonna die I can't I
can't find it I can remember testifying
before one committee and the audience
was so around that the Chairman had to
back bang the gavel that the key to shut
them down and and they put some little
tiny thing in it in the law they were
building and and I would bet the rent
money that that provision is gone now
because there are so many people who
didn't why I was saying that if you're
gonna help up for kids
then give the money to the kids are you
know from provided for wherever they go
don't turn it over to the institutions
because they they will then use it in an
entirely different way are there any
examples where the money is turned over
to the institution whatever the
institution might be where it really
does work are there any aberrations in
most the must there must be some where
by law of averages but is not prevalent
yeah so a couple times you've mentioned
liberals and one of the things that I
talked about on my show often because I
was I was a progressive I was I was a
lefty I now call myself a classical
liberal and I've tried to make the point
that being a liberal in the traditional
sense has very little if anything to do
with the left anymore
yes are there any do you see any sort of
meaningful distinction between classical
liberal and libertarian at this point or
or do you see even I'll ask you a couple
things at once and you can go any
direction do you see any are there do
you see a difference of course between
liberals and the left I mean the words
have all sort of yeah no I'm free-range
to always say that he was he was a
liberal sort of Hayek and and of course
in different countries the word means
different things are in Australia if you
said you were a liberal they would
understand what you were saying but in
it what a liberal and is Australia is
different from a liberal in the United
States yeah so when you say liberal you
mean leftist basic yeah and the American
sense of the word yeah do you think
there's any sort of real distinction
that needs to be made between classical
liberal and libertarian that that's one
of the things that people ask me all the
time and I know you're not big on labels
generally but I did read something where
you said that the closest thing that you
could be labeled as is libertarian is
that still where you're at yeah except
of course in foreign policy we can talk
about that too
and and and I guess also the little of
libertarians seem to have this atomistic
view of the world which i think is
completely unrealistic yeah sighs oh
good because I mean not only in my life
but in the lives of people around me the
surroundings make a huge difference one
of the things I get into a lot in in the
book is this the disparities imply
either either discrimination on the one
hand or genetic differences on the other
and disparities are the norm I mean I
was just reading something the other day
you know that Latin America has 8% of
the people in the world they commit 38%
of all the murders I and in Latin
America 80% no third 38% for that but in
Latin America eighty percent of the
murders occur on 2% of the streets Wow
so but you find that when you look look
up facts that's what you find over and
over again and it in all the discussions
of income the differences they acted
that it they never take into account age
an age is huge I mean japanese-americans
have a median age of 50 Hispanic
Americans has
26 now when you see Hispanic Americans
greatly over-represented among baseball
stars and not a single Japanese American
baseball star in the major leagues I
don't believe in entire history yeah
well we had each hero on scene oh no no
no that was there are people of Japanese
ancestry who've been become baseball
stars yeah all of them are from Japan
none of them are Japanese America hi
okay fair enough right he played he was
a star in Japan for that that's right
yeah so so so how many 50-year old men
are gonna be baseball stars yeah and by
the same token how many 20 26 year-old
men are gonna be surgeons or CEOs any
other kind of job that requires a long
years of study or and or long years of
experience and so even if they were the
same if the two groups were the same in
every other way and if there was
absolutely no distinction no
discrimination and whatnot they still
would be a huge difference in income
simply because of age and and that
really is what this book is about and
you know the book itself it's about a
hundred 60 pages but what I loved
you know many pages have notes you have
in there yep do you know offhand Wayne
well I know I know 127 pages are texts
and the rest of it is notes
yeah so you had about 30 some odd pages
notes and I actually started going
through the notes because I thought this
is this is exactly what we need now we
you know like when I was reading it
there were pages that I had to read more
than once because you're obviously
giving a lot of numbers and facts and
you have to look at these things from
different angles and we're not very good
at that these days right we're sort of
know knows from one angle and then and
then you start the screaming and I think
that's what you're you're really a
master up here yeah well thank you I'm
trying I try to but we'll see how it
works out we'll see do you make any
meaningful distinction between sort of a
classical liberal and a libertarian is
that is that just sort of that's wholly
peripheral that's what I'm coming there
just trying to get a few simple facts
across it's a full-time job yeah all
right so let's talk about some of the
facts that you lay out in the book you
talk about two types of discrimination
could yeah the word has almost opposite
meanings I mean the first meaning when
they say yes someone has discriminating
tastes you mean he can tell what
a good wine from a bad wine what does a
good camera from a [ __ ] and so forth
and that's almost the exact opposite of
the meaning and in the law where you
mean someone who judges someone by what
group he comes from irrespective of the
individuals actual personal qualities so
that no those are two very different
things
ideally you would like every person to
be judged as an individual but as a
practical matter that becomes impossible
because the costs are prohibitive yes I
use the example where if you're walking
down at night and and you see a shadowy
figure in an alley up ahead I mean do
you judge him as an individual or do you
cross the street and go across on the
other side because the cost of judging
him as an individual can be very high
including your life so so we make that
distinction but then I say that I call
that discriminate discrimination 1/1 is
when you just have a very good
understanding of what the facts are and
so if you judge this person as an
individual I call that discrimination 1a
and then if you judge them by the group
they belong to that's not as good but
that's discrimination wouldn't be but
it's still based on some facts a
discrimination tool which is what reason
we have any discrimination laws is that
you don't worry about that at all if
he's someone that you don't like for
whatever reason then you you you you you
know biased against him
yeah are you shocked when you look at
what's going on right now and and see so
much talk about race all the time so
much talk about all of the things that
separate us the very things that that
you've been arguing against based in
fact for so many years that seem in an
odd way more I don't think there's more
racism now than ever or more of these
dividers but there's more talk about it
yes and it's devastating I mean what
wars in general are much easier to start
than they ought to stop I mean when when
when that fellow in in Serbia shot the
Archduke I mean who knew that that was
going to millions of people around the
world including people from the United
States about it's about ten thousand
miles away and I call
with install shooting yeah great war
yeah and and you can't get and you get
and I'm worried about the truck current
trade war you start a trade war you may
never be able to stop it in and then in
the next decade because there are too
many people involved too many crossed
currents of interest and so on what
would you do about our school systems oh
my goodness I'll trial you try to be
rational do try yeah there they are so
awful but the public has no idea what
I'm reading a book about schools and the
woman who's writing a Diane Ravitch is
talking about how teachers have due
process before they can be fired now
when you look into the facts of it right
down here and I think there's a certain
they cost a half a million dollars to
fire one incompetent teacher you know
you don't have a big enough budget you
know and right and the in New York yes
when I call the rubber room is it
teachers who are so incompetent that the
principal's don't want them in the
classroom you know and they get paid
full salary and they show up and they
accrue pension rights and so forth and
the last time I forget how many millions
of dollars are spent a year in New York
paying for teachers who don't teach and
in fact don't do anything but show up at
the same time as if they were teaching
and they read magazines or whatever they
feel like doing and this this force goes
on at a time when they don't have enough
money to provide the kids with decent
supplies so how do we scale back this I
mean you can talk we can talk about it
through the lens of Education but in any
nna area where the government has taken
on a bigger role than it's supposed to I
think one of the things you hear all the
time is it's sort of too late I think a
lot of people think it's too late to
take back no government power
no you heavens uh during the Reagan
administration that was the only time I
know of when the Federal Register grew
smaller that is where they compiled all
the laws that have been passed in a
given time so it can be done it's not
it's not it's not it's not and that's
not easy but it can't be done
someone wants to do some issue with said
Reagan was discussing and someone say
you know it it's complicated
he said it's not complicated it's just
not easy to do I mean right now we're I
one of the big forces out here it talks
about affordable housing and they're
appointing blue-ribbon committees to
look into why there's no affordable
housing and I think that's that's like
appointing a blue-ribbon committee to
explain and why the ground is wet after
a rain I mean it's very simple if you
prevent people from building housing and
the population is growing you're gonna
have a housing shortage yeah and you
won't have affordable housing it's
really you know economics one during the
first first two weeks they're not very
good at taking economics one I don't
think so so when your answer it be in
almost every case to just scale back
government scale back regulation is the
president what they're doing there were
some things that government is necessary
to do so what are those type of things
they owe security first of all having
having dependable laws up some people
think that if you're for free markets
that means you don't think the
government should do anything no you can
the free markets don't operate except
within a framework of laws that's wholly
different from having them operate with
politicians jumping in unpredictable
times to suddenly pass some new
legislation yeah what can we do right
now I mean so really this would be about
just sort of electing more libertarian
minded politicians then I mean is that
really the only way we can change things
do you think no I think the main thing
people have to know what the facts are
themselves if everyone knew what all the
facts were I think you'd have an
entirely different set of set of people
elected i I can't believe that either of
the presidential candidates in 19th in
2016 would have would have been the
candidates if you had an informed public
how much of this do you think is part of
the media's fault that's one of the
things well the media are mostly
uninformed no no they're not uninformed
they are misinformed hmm
and and and they simply do not check the
facts
on large issues a small yeah what what
can we do to fix that do you think I
mean I suppose this no no I know yeah
but write books like this well but I
think more fundamentally the public that
votes has to itself become informed and
not be so easily stampeded by slogans
and a few numbers thrown around like you
know women make X percent of what men
make and so on
yeah and when I was started studying
that some years ago for example I found
out that young young female doctors made
much less money than young male doctors
not to seem like those right on and it's
right but when you're looking into it
you discover that young male doctors
work an average of 500 hours a year more
than young female doctors and they get
paid for the 500 hours but but there's
no reason why the women and men should
be doing the same thing their
circumstances are different so are there
any laws that are in place right now
that you believe are discriminatory one
way or another towards any community or
against any community I would have to
write a much larger book to cover them
all the minimum wage law is absolutely
devastating the policy of saying that
you cannot have more kids from one
ethnic group disciplined in the school
and from another is nonsense
I mean groups are different from each
other and umpteen ways and then there's
helis have the presumption that they are
the same except for the way they're
they're treated there's nonsense that's
never been true and I don't know why we
would think it's true here today so I do
sense that some of what you just said
there is bubbling up into the national
consciousness email from black
conservatives now people that feel that
they haven't been represented fairly or
that the the you know the so-called
leaders of the black community that are
on television all the time are actually
preaching the complete reverse of
everything that you've said here yeah do
you sense that there is some sort of
growing conservative movement well no
there was a community there was a time
when when that that community would
consisted of me and
I know all these to say we were the two
it should never fly on the same plane
otherwise the whole moment will
disappear that goes down well I
mentioned to you before we started that
larry elder caused my awakening because
i was a progressive and i said something
to him about systemic racism non-air
manny he beat me senseless with facts
and i had to go back and reassess what
was wrong with my thinking well you know
anyone and one of the one of the
chapters there i have a little section
about the era of apartheid under South
in South Africa and I had that in there
because there's so much argument of how
much racism is there so forth I say
let's test this hypothesis in a setting
where there's absolutely no doubt of it
and that's apartheid in South Africa
with a government where blacks are not
allowed to vote and so forth and you
then apply the economic principle and
you find that the economic principles
apply in South Africa that there are
some occupations see blacks weren't
allowed by law to being certain
occupations more than the same
percentage and in some occupations
couldn't be hired at all and some of
those occupations where they couldn't be
hired at all illegal to hire them at all
there were more blacks hired than there
were whites because there are economic
factors that could come in and you don't
just pass a law and that automatically
produces the results you want yeah can
you go into some of the economic factors
that you mentioned there because I
thought it was sort of interesting about
the types of jobs that they've had and
why that would affect well it's it's no
it's the competitiveness of the industry
and a competitive industry
discrimination and then in the sense
that we that we use for
anti-discrimination laws it costs the
discriminator as well as the others now
insofar as that price can be evaded by
the discriminated he will he will
describe for example minimum wage laws
let when you have a minimum wage law you
have more people applying for jobs in
those categories then there are jobs
available because the Razr were aging
the wage rate causes more people to
apply and employers to hire fewer
because they're more expensive and so we
have a chronic surplus now if you've got
a chronic surplus in an industry it
costs nothing to discriminate
but and I and and but but if you have a
competitive market then of course it
does cost something for every person
that you discriminate against was
qualified you've got to hire somebody
else and you got to raise that pave cut
rate in order to get people in so I show
how competitive industries have much
less discrimination than say regulated
public utilities so I was wondering when
I was reading it if you were ever going
to talk about how now technology is also
changing this so we see a lot of these
movements for $15 minimum wage and I
know why you don't think that's a great
idea
but even now where we see McDonald's and
some of these other places just
replacing people with yes and computers
this has been happening I don't know
when I grew up in Harlem when you went
into a movie theater this is a little
neighborhood movie theater in Harlem
there would be a kid who would walk back
down the aisle with you with a
flashlight to show you to you to see you
see and so now now that we have so many
compassionate people who wanted people
to be paid a minute a living wage you
actually stumbled down the charge that
down the aisle to your seat the best way
you can yeah because they're not going
to pay that kind of money you know
that's unrelated to productivity yeah
what would you say to the people I hear
a growing movement of people saying well
this is why we need a universal basic
income because technology is going to
force for so many people out of the
workplace
oh and that has been and that is that
always has been made for centuries and
it has been proven wrong for centuries I
would ask the question what has happened
we've moved in that direction already we
have lots of people who can live off the
welfare say and not and not and not
haven't had to be productive and are
they better people as a result of that
one of I saw some time back and I
haven't followed this that young people
is suicide rates among young people were
among the negative consequences of the
1960s people you you you've taken all
meaning out of people's lives and so
they find all kinds of crazy things to
do drugs whatever and then again it's
not peculiar to deny
States as he find us in Britain other
countries and so again people who say
this almost never look at any facts
about what's happened as we expanded the
welfare state that people behave better
no you know I mean what I want one of
the one of the things that the moments
that I remember very well when I was I
was back in the school in Harlem for
some reason maybe doing research and I
looked out the window and I said said
you know I when I was a teenager I used
to walk at all
my dog in that Park and look look sohara
came over the students faces because
that was a different world and so and
and when I tell them that I used to
sleep out on a fire escape on hot summer
nights go who who could afford
air-conditioning and they think I'm a
man from all people did that all over
New York they did it in Washington they
did it in North Carolina relatives were
in Washington used to go down and Haines
point down near the Jefferson Memorial
on hot summer nights and sleep there so
you know sometime after midnight when
they didn't win their heat wouldn't be
so bad they'd go home at that time yeah
you'd be out of your mind to do that
today it'd be too dangerous yeah so how
do we sort of untie some of this so my
sister right now lives on the Upper West
Side of Manhattan not too far from
Harlem and she's in a half rent
stabilizer rent-controlled building and
in half market price she's on the market
price so she's paying that to be in a
bedroom in New York City I don't even
want to tell you how expensive it is but
then there are basically half of the
building that's paying next to nothing
and that of course incentivizes people
not to get off the dole because if
you're living in a nice area on the
Upper West Side very cheap why in the
world would you ever get off the dole
how do we start solving these problems
and I know I know facts is your is your
bedrock ends yes but but what can we do
to get people to understand some of this
stuff because it's it seems so basic to
understand if someone was giving you
something that you didn't earn again
there's a sorry to this again this is
common one of this and in Europe in
England especially it's a special
problem because you have to you have
this
where the urine is subsidized and say
you're in London and jobs are
disappearing in London and they are
opening up in Manchester now if you go
to Manchester you know you know you get
on a waiting list for that kind of job
and if you stand in London you're
unemployed but your rent is low and so
Peter so you slow down the movement of
people you slow down the turnover of
people in these apartments but again
most people who talk about this don't
even talk in terms of if this than that
they talk about it is this is how the
world ought to be well heck I got all
kinds of things throughout I think the
world ought to be but unfortunately most
of those things involve a cost of
trade-offs do you think there's a system
or a government that's doing it better
doing freedom better than we're doing it
here for all the flaws that we have in
this in this system is anyone doing it
better than us although there may be
marginally so but I think most of the
Western world is less free than than it
was say 30 years ago 40 years ago by
what measurements do you view that oh
just the amount of regulations things
you could use and and also by
consequences either I was reading of
Milton Friedman's he and his wife had a
joint autobiography and she's looking at
one point she looking back on in the
days when she would ride the IND subway
in Manhattan and what a joy it was and
she said in those long-gone days and the
IND subway goes through Harlem and
Milton Friedman and his wife and they
were still quoting used to go dancing at
the Savoy Ballroom very few people want
wanted and you know the famous theme
song of Duke Ellington take the A train
the a train goes right through Harlem on
the I in these line and so Friedman who
was only five foot two had no fear of
being mugged or even a costume and go
there they were and this was common it
wasn't where there was a black actress
who used to get finished with play and
her socializing afterwards at one
o'clock in the morning
says she would be taking the subway up
to 150 5th Street in st. Nicholas Avenue
by herself
and what I'm walking home nobody does
that these days and so you have to look
wanted what are the facts how did they
change and and and you don't simply say
the other thing is that they're saying
the No Child Left Behind thing with Bush
mm-hmm yeah there are kids who go to
school to raise hell and a handful of
those can prevent the whole class from
learning anything now the logical thing
would be to separate those kids out and
that ones who wanted to learn something
learn something you can't do that
because the ideology says no and again
so and so you sacrifice whole
generations of poor and minority kids
for this ideology and this utopian
notion yeah and and we end up in an odd
dystopia probably yeah I'm the favor you
can say the best is the enemies are good
and of course it would be better if
everybody could be educated at the same
time it can't be done so as someone that
has survived the the arrows and and the
the venom that the left can throw at you
because I see a lot of this these days I
see you even what they say to me I find
I get a lot of email from people saying
well how can I be brave enough to do it
and I think it's particularly a unique
situation for minorities that consider
themselves conservative or libertarian
or a little bit to the right so I've
mentioned larry elder before and of
course you and my friend David Webb and
I you know there there are some more
black conservatives than perhaps there
used to be oh no question about what
would be if someone's watching this
right now and just needs that little
extra bit of courage to start saying no
no no no you have to look at this
circumstances
I mean I've advised some young people do
not go into two ended teaching in public
schools because the odds are so stacked
against you and people can write bad
references from you for you between
specially when you're young and you and
what they say about you is all that that
someone sees now by the time I was
at some of these schools I remember one
place where the department chairman used
to threaten wonder why my colleagues he
wouldn't write good rap references for
him I had I had you know I publish stuff
while I was still in graduate school I
had Milton Friedman and Joyce Taylor the
right references Murray what this guy
said there share a little department
wouldn't wouldn't matter a bit but but
most people don't don't have that
situation yeah and so you have to pick
you yet to pick your face so I want to
time is limited here I want to mention
one thing that you say right at the end
of the book that really what we need
more than anything else perhaps is
common decency and we've kind of lost
that isn't common anymore I mean when I
was going to school and we'd have fights
on the schoolyard grounds when once one
guy was clearly beaten whoever was the
toughest kids in the crowd would simply
step in and stop it the other guys he
said you want a fight and you can fight
me yeah that we need in the public
square now yes yes but but when it would
I mean the pool is only so much the
police can do if you don't have common
decency that the the cops have are not
not going to be able to handle it
especially when everyone is
second-guessing it I love it when people
who have never fired a gun in their
lives say why does it cops fire so many
guns now at one time I taught pistol
shooting in the Marine Corps it doesn't
surprise me in the slightest of a shot
fired so many things under those
conditions what people feel people can't
be knowledgeable about everything but
they can be knowledgeable about the
extent of their own ignorance even if
they have PhDs sir
this has been a true honor and a
pleasure and I know I can see it in your
eyes even the sort of humility that you
have in homeless but you you've affected
so many people and are still continuing
to affect so many people and I hope that
we might have just given that a little
extra bump today so I'm truly honored
that you took your time all Thank You
Rory was
you
[Music]